here's my question cuz like people watch
reality TV and I'm like how real is
reality TV cuz there's cameras there so
that's not real right so listen I uh
yes it's what the good and bad part so
I'm on season 1 so I didn't know any
better than to just act myself I didn't
know I didn't ease keep doing that don't
be weird
what you happy yeah I didn't know how
much of it would be on TV or whatever I
mean they said ok no other cameras just
go about your daily business so you know
I went about my daily business I was on
the bidet I'm getting into my you know
my man's space wait a minute now little
did I know that this was going to end up
on TV oh my god I actually want to be
such good friends with you like the fact
that you did that is I talk about my
Spanx all the time so openly it's so
great yeah but I'm a man thanks
well now I know listen I didn't know if
this bank community for men was like
less like like when she thought was
underground
[Laughter]
[Applause]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going